direkt an der kleinen ortschaft rampen
auf der insel rügen in mecklenburg
vorpommern für die b 96 vorbei auf der
neuen umgehungsstraße sollte eigentlich
so genannter flüsterasphalt verbaut
werden
stattdessen wurden mit betonplatten
verlegt die anwohner sind stinksauer
weil die straße so unglaublich laut ist
wir fühlen uns hier total verarscht es
gibt einen planfeststellungsverfahren da
steht drin was drauf soll das ist der
beton unsere beton ruine und die
leidtragenden ist sie ihre gesamte
gemeindegebiet man ist eigentlich
fassungslos weil man sagt wie sollen wir
das verstehen es wurde alles
ausgeschrieben
es wurden die vorgaben schriftlich
fixiert und dann hält sich keiner dran
durch die verlegung der alten
bundesstraße fließt der verkehr nicht
mehr durch rambin sondern drumherum
aber jetzt rasen die autos mit 100
sachen direkt am ort vorbei
wegen dieses lärms sollte die neue
bundesstraße einen belag aus
flüsterasphalt bekommen schön wär's
gewesen denn die angeblich beste lösung
war dann plötzlich auf höhe der gesamten
ortslage ein fahrbahnbelag aus
waschbeton wir fühlen uns einfach
bedrohung passten genau auf höhe der
ortschaft wir diesen beton bekommen
haben werden außerhalb der ortschaft
infeld lage
derzeit ist wenn sie das abfahren merken
sie jedes auto merkt das wenn dieser
belag herkommt und nimmt ein erheblich
höheres geräusch war im zuständigen
schweriner verkehrsministerium gesteht
man das problem mittlerweile ein und
verspricht eine lösung schriftlich heißt
es im ergebnis weiterer untersuchungen
zur lebenssituation im bereich der
ortslage rambin soll nun zusätzlich eine
lärmschutzwand errichtet werden
doch die idee ist nicht neu denn auf
dieser lärmschutzwand warten die
menschen in rambin nun auch schon seit
jahren es passiert einfach nichts
darüber dass man uns sachen versprochen
hat schon vor jahren die nicht
eingehalten worden sind da muss einfach
erst mal überhaupt eine lärmschutzwand
her aber allgemein für die ganze
ortschaft einfach eine bessere farben
oberfläche gesprochen worden ist und
schallschutz waren bis jetzt ist nichts
passiert immer nur leere worte für die
lärmschutzwand muss jetzt erst noch ein
planänderungsverfahren durchgezogen
werden bis es in rambin einen
vernünftigen lärmschutz geben wird
werden wohl noch tausende fahrzeuge über
die neue bundesstraße 96 brettern